[موسيقى]
بتوقع انه ممكن بعد 20 سنه نضطر نروح على
الشغل ممكن انا عادي افتح الكمبيوتر تبعي
اتحكم بروبوت يروح عني على الشغل ويعمل
ادائي انا يعني بس اكون انا قاعد بتحكم
فيه من البيت
يمكن ما تكون موجوده وهيك ولانه بحس
الحياه راح تصير كثير متطوره اكتر يعني ما
بتعرفوا ممكن نصير نقدر نروح مثلا رحله
على الفضاء بالعطله او اشي زي هيك عملت 19
سنه بتخيل الحياه حتكون كتير اسهل حيكون
في روبوت ما حنضطر نروح على شغل حيكون كله
اونلاين نشتغل من البيت انا عمري 20 سنه
ممكن نكون احنا جيل الياقه بنقذ العالم
بتغير المناخي من المشاكل هاي الكوارث عم
بتصير ممكن احنا يا اما ننقل العالم من
هاي الاشياء او ممكن ندمره يعني عمري 23
سنه تمام بعد 20 سنه بصراحه ممكن اتخيل
ماي بيست فريند يكون روبوت تمام لانه
الدنيا ما عليها شمال هذه الفتره ههه
[موسيقى]
الاعلام هو دائما مواكب للتطورات وللتطور
التكنولوجي بالاخص
بتوقع انه راح يتم توظيف هاي تطورات وخاصه
بالمجال الاعلامي ممكن نستفاد من هون
بارسالهم لمناطق النزاع وساحات الحروب
عوضا عن الصحفيين والمصورين يلي عم
بخاطروا بحياتهم من اجل ينقلوا لنا
الاخبار الرئيس الكوري 24 سنه في بل جهز
جوابي شوي برايي انه بعد عشرين سنه راح
يكون العالم
تطور كتير على الصعيد التكنولوجي وعلى
الصعيد
المهني ان منكون ربحنا وقت وقت من خلال
التكنولوجيا وهذا الوقت اللي بنكون ربحناه
راح نقدر نطور فيك يومنا الانسانيه من
خلال التطوع بالجمعيات او من خلال الاعمال
اليدويه والاحترافيه للتكنولوجيا ما راح
تقدر يكون عندها هيدا
الروح تقدر تعملها بعد 20 سنه ممكن اتخيل
حياه طويله اكثر كنا نتلقى الاخبار من
التلفزيون هلا صرنا نتلقى الاخبار من
الانترنت من تلفوناتنا يعني حتى الزلازل
لاول ما سمعنا انه صار في زلزال انا اول
شيء تلاقيته هو من الانستغرام من الفيسبوك
فبعتقد بعد عشرين سنه كمان راح يصير في
تطور اكبر البشريه رح تتقدم اكثر وراح
يصير في عنا تطور على الصعيد التكنولوجي
اكبر انا اوجه العودات عمري 22 سنه انا
طالبه بجامعه الجديده بعد 20 سنه بتوقع
على المجتمعات رح تنقسم لنصفين نصف ضد
التكنولوجيا واللي راح يرجع لانه يرجعوا
للحياه البدائيه للانسان البسيطه والجزء
الثاني راح يكون الناس اللي رح تستغل يعني
تجمع ثروات وهذا اكثر شيء بيخوفني يعني
انه يصير الواقع افتراضي هو الواقع الصح
ونصير يعني الطبقه اللي بتكون اكثر مظلومه
هي الناس اللي بدها تبتعد عن التكنولوجيا